Transcriber: Nihal Aksakal
Gözden geçirme: Saliha Karatepeli
Merhabalar, ben sizi görmüyorum.
İsmim Ahmet, konuşarak
hayatımı kazanıyorum.
7 yıldır Bilgi Üniversitesi'nde
öğretim görevlisiyim.
Ondan önce Anadolu'da neredeyse
gitmediğim üniversite kalmadı.
Girişimcilik hikâyemi anlatıyorum.
İşin ilginç yanı TEDx’e davet edildiğimde
önce çok mutlu oldum.
Çok heyecanlandım.
Çok klasik, egom okşandı
ve işim bu, konuşuyorum.
Bir problem vardı.
Benim konuşmalarım minimum
bir saat sürüyor.
Genelde 3 saate kadar uzuyor
ve bana söyledikleri zaman
“Maksimum 15 dakika konuşacaksın Ahmet.”
dedikleri zaman ciddi bir stres oldum.
Önce şunu yaptım. YouTube'a girdim,
TEDx diye arama yaptım
ve en çok izlenenden en az izlenene doğru
izlemeye başladım
ve bir baktım çok farklı konularda
yıllardır izlediğim TEDx konuşmaları
dışında,
çok farklı konular var
ve genelde iş konuşmak istemiyorum bugün,
genelde çok ulvi konulara değiniyorlar.
Dedim ben de ulvi bir konuya değineyim.
Ne anlatayım? Başarıyı anlatıyım,
başarının sırrını anlatayım.
Eminim herkes merak ediyor değil mi,
başarının sırrını?
Merak etmeyen var mı?
Edenler bir el kaldırabilir mi?
Herkes ediyor.
Şu an yaşadığımız dünyada
ve özellikle bizim toplumumuzda
başarının belli kriterleri var.
Türkçede hatta biz elalem ne der
diyoruz ya.
Çok önemli bir etken hayatımızda
değil mi?
Başarının belli kriterleri var.
Bizim toplumumuza bakalım.
Çok küçükken olay nasıl başlıyor?
Çok çalışıyoruz.
İyi bir okul kazanıyoruz.
Başarılıyız değil mi teknik olarak.
Millet başarılı diyor.
Sonra daha çok çalışıyoruz.
Daha iyi bir okula gidiyoruz.
Çevremiz, akrabalarımız,
ailemiz diyor ki bu çocuk çok başarılı.
Sonra daha çok çalışıp iyi bir
üniversiteye gidiyoruz.
Çok başarılı oluyoruz.
Üniversite bitiyor, ne yapıyoruz?
Diyorlar ki artık iyi bir eş bul,
düzgün bir eş bul, evlen.
Evleniyoruz.
Evlenince ne oluyor?
Başarılı oluyoruz değil mi?
Daha sonra ne oluyor?
Vakti geldi artık hayırlı bir evlat
dünyaya getir diyorlar.
Evladın oluyor, başarılı oluyorsun
ve belli bir noktada yaş ilerlemeye
başlayınca
iş hayatında başarının en önemli kriteri
çok para kazanman oluyor aslında.
Bunu dile getirelim getirmeyelim
bu böyle oluyor
ve ben dedim ki ben başarının
sırrını anlatayım,
ulvi bir şey olsun.
Vurucu bir konuşma olsun,
bunu 15 dakikaya sığdırayım.
Sonra düşündüm, ben boşanmış bir adamım.
Çocuğum yok.
Yaşım, tecrübem ve okuduğum okullara göre
emin olun çok param yok.
TEDx videosu olarak eminim çok izlenirdi
ama TEDx Fail diye aradıklarında
Youtube’da çok izlenirdi
ve başarıyı anlatmamaya karar verdim.
Geçen sene doğum günümde
bir de şeyi düşündüm,
“En kötü ihtimal ne olabilir?
En kötü ihtimal başarıyı anlatmam.
Ne anlatacağım?”
Geçen sene doğum günümde
şöyle bir olay oldu.
Her doğum gününde oturursun
bir düşünürsün ya
geçen senem nasıl geçti,
önümüzdeki yıl nasıl geçecek,
planlar yaparsın ve benim bazı şeyleri
sorguladığım bir dönemdi o ara.
Doğum günümde şunu düşündüm:
Ben mutlu muyum?
Mutluluğu sorgulamaya başladım
ve şuna eminim herkesin kendine göre
mutluluk kriterleri var.
Çoğu zaman bunu dillendirmiyoruz.
Kendimize bile dillendirmiyoruz
ve ben aynanın karşısına geçip
“Ahmet mutlu musun?” diye
kendime sordum.
Bu çok iyi bir şey.
Bugün yapacağım tek tavsiye şu:
Aynanın karşısına geçip mutlu muyum
diye kendinize sorun.
Ben kendime göre 3 farklı kriter
belirledim.
Bu kriterlere doğru cevap verebiliyorsam
ben Ahmet olarak mutluyum.
Herkesin kriterleri çok farklı.
İsterseniz bu akşam oturun düşünün.
Kalem kağıt alın bunları yazın,
hiç fark etmez.
Benim burada amacım size ne mutluluğu
öğretmek ne anlatmak.
Ben kendi kriterlerimden bahsedeceğim.
Kendimce üç tane kriter belirledim.
Birincisinin şöyle bir hikayesi var.
Benim bir amcamın kızı var.
Benden 6 yaş büyük, Aysun ablam.
Çocukluğumda örnek aldığım
insanlardan biriydi.
Hani insanın hayatında
bilgin insanlar olur ya,
böyle çok ilginç sözler söylerler,
bazen bir hareketini bile
örnek alırsınız.
Ben Aysun ablamı hep örnek aldım.
Aysun ablam çocuk felci,
hiçbir zaman yürüyemedi.
Ben 11 yaşındayken ona
bir soru sormuştum.
“Aysun abla yürüyememek
nasıl bir duygu?” demiştim.
O da bana düşün daha 16-17 yaşında
o bilgeliği ile
şöyle bir cevap vermişti:
“Ahmet uçamamak nasıl bir duygu?” demişti
ve ben o zaman bile,
biliyorum Aysun ablam sıradan,
normal cevap vermiyor,
ciddi ciddi bunu düşünmüştüm.
Geçen sene doğum günümde
Aysun ablama sorduğum o soru
ve cevabı aklıma geldi.
Bana demişti ki tekrar söylüyorum:
“Ahmet uçamamak nasıl bir duygu?”
ve şunu düşündüm.
Ben aslında hayallerinin peşinden
koşunca mutlu olan bir adamım.
Ben bir girişimciyim ve dedim ki
benim başarıda birinci kriterim
hayal bile edemeyeceğim
hayallerin peşinde koşmak.
Ne zaman ben, iş hayatım olsun,
normal özel hayatım olsun,
yaptığım bütün işlerde geçmişimde,
hayal bile edemeyeceğim,
hayallerimin peşinden koştuysam
mutlu olmuşum.
İkincisi yine benim için bilge bir insan.
Rahmetli babam hayatı boyunca
insanlara bir şekilde dokunarak
hayatını geçirdi.
O vefat ettiği gün ben bunu anlamıştım.
Bir hafta telefonum susmadı.
Binlerce kişi Anadolu'nun,
dünyanın dört bir yanından aradı
ve babamın onların hayatlarına
nasıl dokunduğunu bana anlattılar.
Çoğu hikâyeyi hiç bilmiyordum bile
ve ben insanların hayatına
bir şekilde dokununca
çok mutlu olduğuma karar verdim.
Bunu çok ulvi düşünmeyin.
Birisinin hayatını değiştirmek gibi
düşünmeyin.
Tatilinizde belki çıkıp gönüllü olup
Anadolu'da bir üniversiteye gidip
sadece kendi hikayenizi anlatıp
orada birkaç kişiye
bir kıvılcım çakmak bile insanların
hayatına dokunmak dedim
ve ben insanların hayatlarına dokununca
mutluyum dedim
ve ilginç bir şekilde üçüncü kriterde de
Kenan Doğulu benim için çok etkili oldu.
Ne iş yaparsam yapayım aşkla,
heyecanla yaptığım zaman
mutlu olduğumu fark ettim
ve ben dedim ki bundan sonra hayatımda
ne yaparsam yapayım
hayal bile edemeyeceğim hayallerin
peşinden koştuğum zaman,
gerçekten insanların hayatına dokunuyorsam
ve yaptığım iş ne olursa olsun sonucu
hiç önemli değil bakın,
başarı kriterlerine uygun olmasına
hiç gerek yok.
Hele hele ülkemizdeki
başarı kriterlerine.
Sonu ne olursa olsun ben aşkla,
heyecanla ayağa kalkıp
o işi yapıyorsam benim için
sonu mutlulukla biten bir süreç
olduğuna %100 karar verdim
ve ben geçen yıl doğum günümden beri
bu kuralı her gün uyguluyorum.
Kendime “Ahmet mutlu musun?”
diye soruyorum.
Şöyle ilginç bir şey var.
Dünyanın önde gelen bir üniversitesinde
özellikle psikoloji
ve sosyoloji bölümlerinde yapılan
bazı doktora çalışmaları var.
Bakın üç çeşit ölüm var aslında.
Birincisi ani ölüm, trafik kazası gibi
birçok sebepten olabilir.
İkincisi uzun süren bir hastalıkla ölüm.
Üçüncüsü de yaşlılıktan ölüm.
Benim incelediğim birkaç araştırmada
ölüm döşeğinde olan yaşlılara
klişe, klasik sorulan belli sorular var
ve bunlar çok ilginç bir şekilde
Harvard Üniversitesi'nde
bir doktora tezinde benim çok ilgimi
çeker şekilde sonuçlar vermiş.
Beklediğimiz klişe cevaplar var.
Şu soruluyor, deniyor ki
“Bugün ölüm döşeğindesin,
tekrar geçmişe gitsen,
bu hayatı tekrar yaşasan
en büyük pişmanlığın ne?”
Benim ilgimi çeken soru bu.
Bu soruyu eminim birçoğumuz
merak etmişizdir.
Verilen cevapların çoğunda neler var?
Neler var biliyor musunuz?
Çocuklarıma, aileme daha çok
vakit ayırırdım, daha az çalışırdım.
İşe hayatına bu kadar saldırmazdım,
bu kadar hırslı olmazdım.
Bir şekilde daha az çalışırdım.
Çok klişe başka cevaplar da var.
Burada çok ilginç, ilk 3'te daha fazla
seks yapardım da var.
İlginç bir şekilde ve ben dedim ki
ben bir gün ölüm döşeğinde olsam
ve bana deseler ki
“En büyük pişmanlığın ne,
şu anda geri dönsen ne yapardın Ahmet?”
Şunu düşündüm ben geri dönsem gerçekten,
gerçekten aşkla, heyecanla,
bir şekilde insanların hayatına
dokunacak şekilde,
hayal bile kuramadığım hayallerin
peşinden koşmak isterdim
ve tek pişmanlığım ne olurdu
biliyor musunuz?
O denemediğim, denemediğim şeyler olurdu
ve buna karar verdim.
Bundan sonra her gün en az
bir kez aynanın karşısında
“Ahmet mutlu musun?”
diye kendime soruyorum
ve hayatıma giren sevdiğim dostlarıma,
arkadaşlarıma da bunu soruyorum.
Çok teşekkür ederim beni
dinlendiğiniz için.